well first of all I should say that I
I'm not particularly comfortable with
being described as a religious person
because somehow I have this image in my
mind of of somebody who's who's very
proper and and prim and follows all
sorts of rituals and stuff and and I
like rather to describe myself as a
person of faith and clearly I don't
believe that science has made belief in
God obsolete or else I wouldn't describe
myself as a person of faith I believe
that certain ways of interpreting
certain scriptures have been made
obsolete by science but that in no way
makes religious faith or belief in God
obsolete it just requires what I would
consider to be a different outlook a
maturation of religious faith but if we
look at the history of religious faith
as told in the scriptures and as seen
throughout history I think the entire
history of faith has been one of a
maturation of that faith I see it not so
much as people becoming more mature in
their faith but God challenging people
to become more mature to get a clearer
understanding of what God wants for
humankind and I think God is always
pushing us to be better than what we are
okay so there's two ways of answering
that question by and large science and
religion deal with different kinds of
questions science deals with questions
about how do things come to be the way
they are how should I think about the
way things are how shall I organize my
understanding of the way things behave
whereas religion deals with questions
like how should I behave toward my
fellow human creatures what should my
relationship be to God how should I
understand the ultimate origins of this
world in this universe in which we live
these are very different kinds of
questions but sometimes the areas that
science addresses and the areas that
religion addresses can overlap so I
don't ascribe to the idea of science and
religion as being non-overlapping
magisteria as they've sometimes been
described but I also will say that by
and large they deal with different kinds
of questions but there are ethical
questions that might involve things like
medical ethics or environmental
questions where you have to understand
the science in order to be able to make
good ethical decisions that are guided
by your religious principles so there's
always going to be places where science
and religion are going to come to bear
on the same kinds of problems